LEBRATING
TOYING GOOD RICEA ICOF CON
EPRESENTIV
INSISTS HE COULD HAVE SURVIV A
CHALLENGE,
THN  A CAN
RVOU RN
S ARHE
FO PREPANEL IS BAC THE PERSOO O.
HE BIEHE COULD HAVRI ONC STAR I
WANT AIEF  AMO.C.
>> THAT WAS THE MOST
OATION WITH M.
HEKNOWCOULD HAVE PUTR THMOY TAC,
BUT DNT TO COMBACK.
TRUMP HOE CAUCUS.
INE WI T MNDR THE NEXT YEAR TO K
NCRUYCITI THINK THATOG THAT
WHEREIN PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOS
POT STORIES IN THIS YEAR'SCONGR
TO THIPATHE CONVERSA MINUTE.
SOME SE,E .
BUT TRUMP IS SO PO, MAYB W THE .
WE'LL COME TO THAT PART IN
R
>> EXILY IN
THTHAT WE'RE
GOING TO G TWO
YED POTENTIAUR.'S GOINGHEFUNDRAO
TO BE A RT OF. SAY TO THE
REPUBLICANARS -YEAR-OLD GUY.
STATE OF OHIO,ER
YEARS A EVERYBODYYING THIS IS
GE  FIGURE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY,
WANTS NO PART OF IT.
>> TT' FASCINATING.S SOMEONU TH
HEE BENDACKWARDS TO GET KIN ALSO
QUESTIONS ABOUTTHE REPUBLICAN R
EO IS
THE PATH TG BACK POWER  THROUGH
IDATES ARE YOUNGND
PEOPLE GONZA
RUN ANYMOR
TENT
POST NOTHE
THAT'S WHO THEY'REOOKING FOR.D O
Y ISE  THIS IS HOWE'
TON, I'TA
PART OF
>>
>> ANDOU HAVL
TODAY.
HE NEVER SUBTLE.
F
WN IN T HAT, BECAUSE HCOMPELTO
TIE'
HAPPY.EZASQUIT A EA TREMENDOF
NOT SUBTLE A
YOU COULD AT LEAST BE QUIET.
IFOUIS
REPUBLICAT
IS AR
AIDE MAXILO ISAS A COCKY BULLYK
AMERICAN FOOTBALL GUHI FOUY, GR
VERSUS IS TRUMPY CANDIDATE WITH
A.
IT WAS A CASE ON T  SAY BTO RUN
TO NOTE
THAT THE FORMEPR
CELEBRATING.
TH
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK OUT AIN
O  AREHE DOO ANDCEPT FOR IN A V
SMALL TAE CASES LIKELICHENEY KI
IT'SE A SELESITUN T MEAN TE
LIGHTLY. FIRST OF THOSE.
-- IT'S NOT THWHO CLASHED THRUE.
WE SAW A HUGE NUMB OF
ICANS EITHERO RUN FOR
REELECTION.>> AND SO YOU E SOMEU
P REPUBLICANS WHO
HAVE BEEN HU B
ACVOTEHN CATKO.S ROEDE REPUBLAN
MA'VE AL
THEY'RE STDIRE
PRIMARY CHALLENGES AGAINST MOST.
THE REPUBLICANTY BECOME  ING AR
ABOUT S TRP NT.
>> IT'S TOTALLY DETA FTHING ELS.
POLICY.
AT OF TH
FART
IT'S ENTY A PERSON
AND  NOTBO POLIC. TOTALLY SEPAR.
I K  WHAT TROUBLES A
LOT OF CONSERVATIVES ESPECY.S NE
E
I THINK THAT IS A WHOLE
DIFFSET OF FISH. IT'
COIE YOUEET OF OTHER
D 'TEAY THINK OF
AMERICAN POLIC BEING LIKE T  PR
AROUND THE WOHEPOT CAN HAPP HE
THE 2022N JUASED ON G ONLY IS T
S WH CON
OF REPRESENTATIVES WILL BE
GOVERNING FROM THAT STANDPOINT.I
SHOUL
THINKING ABOUT.
>> IF YOU AFTER
ESPECIALLY SAID WEBE
WE WILL YOO SA THIS
DAY, O TRUMP  WINNING THIS ARGU.
>> YEAH.
S UP AWN IN S IFLICAN PART IREC
WHAT NEXT YEAR IS GOING TO B
MURKOWSKI WHO IS THEY S PLUS
SENATOR IN THE GOP WHO TO
CONVICT CAWILL
SAY A LOT.
ANY EVIDENCE THA
N McCA LAU
MORE NUANCED QN, ARE
LL ASAY STOP THIS?
STOP THIS.
STAY OUT OO STAY?G AT ME.
IT'S FINE.
I ASKER IT.
>> I DO THINK YOROM A LOT OF MBE
THEY WOULDE TOOVE FORWARD
AND BIDEANINFLATION.THG. AE E L
NOBODY S T T TD THING D EXECUTE.
BUT NOT PATA
ELECTIONS CONTFTER THE MIDTERM